CBS News: One of the biggest sporting events
on earth.
BBC: It’s a sporting occasion like no other.
Vanemas: And South Korea have scored!
John Oliver: A country even qualified for
it is a cause for huge celebration.
France 24: It was a moment that people were
craving.
It was as if a bottle of champagne had finally
exploded and it was indeed cathartic.
Two-thirds of the team are of immigrant origin.
This is something we should celebrate.
BBC: France beat Croatia in the final in Moscow…
FIFA: Spain are world champions.
FIFA: Italy are champions of the world.
FIFA TV: It is a World Cup final the world
will never forget.
SIERRA: The 2022 World Cup has officially
kicked off in Qatar, with 32 nations competing
for the championship title.
You may have seen some of the big moments
so far - like Saudi Arabia’s crazy upset
of Argentina in the first round.
At the same time, you've probably seen some
of the news coverage too.
This year’s games have been embroiled in
controversy, from Qatar’s human rights abuses,
to FIFA corruption, to political conflicts
happening along the sidelines.
Soccer - AKA Futbol - is the most popular
sport in the world, and every FIFA World Cup
final is watched by billions of fans internationally.
Think of it this way: if aliens studied Earth,
they would probably note in their report that
all humans, regardless of where they live,
are driven to fits of passion by 22 people
kicking a ball up and down a field.
There’s simply nothing else like it on the
planet.
But why?
Why does this game garner such universal attention?
Why do countries spend billions in order to
host?
And what does the World Cup's power mean when
it is wielded by a country like Qatar?
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is why it
matters.
For today’s episode, I sat down with Laurent
Dubois.
He’s the Academic Director of the Karsh
Institute of Democracy, and a professor at
the University of Virginia, where he teaches
a course called Soccer Politics.
Enjoy!
Gabrielle SIERRA: I thought it would be appropriate
to open our chat by telling you that I was
in fact the captain of my high school soccer
team, two years in a row.
We were just truly terrible.
We lost constantly, but I love soccer.
And so in that spirit, we’re an international
relations think tank.
We don’t spend much time discussing sporting
events.
So, why are we talking about the world cup?
Laurent DUBOIS: The way I put it is that every
World Cup final is watched by more human beings
than have ever watched anything before in
the history of the human race.
Right?
Just to put it in context.
SIERRA: Oh, that’s a lot.
DUBOIS: So, you do have, I think the achievement
of some kind of universal competition that
is really shared.
And I think we all know that if you want to
start a conversation probably anywhere in
the world, you can bring up soccer and the
World Cup and most of the time you will have
an interesting conversation and people will
have opinions about it.
And I think that's a certain kind of success,
for all the other issues with it, it's worth
taking stock of that as something pretty remarkable
in our world.
So, the origins of the World Cup, I think
are interesting in that this is a competition
that emerges in the wake of World War I, out
of a certain sentiment, a post-World-War-I
sentiment that was very much linked to the
rise of the rules-based international order
or the project of the League of Nations.
The whole idea that, effectively, the world
was seeing a serious, violent breakdown of
an international set of relationships.
And for those who were boosters of soccer,
they hoped that this kind of sport that was
already well established in many parts of
the world could be a kind of language.
Some people even described it as an Esperanto
at the time.
And the idea would be that understanding that
people were going to continue to be focused
on their nations and want to represent and
be proud of their nations.
But was there a way of doing that, that was
not a war-like relationship, but an engagement
and a set of rules.
SIERRA: Flash forward a century.
The World Cup has not ended war - but it has
become the most popular event on Earth.
For decades, it was dominated by two regions:
Europe, and Latin America.
But in 2010, something unexpected happened.
FIFA president Sepp Blatter announced that
for the first time in history, the world cup
would be held in the Middle East, in the tiny
petrostate of Qatar.
https://www.youtube.com/watch?v=YfyPi5MnPSY
PBS NewsHour: The winner to organize the 2022
FIFA World Cup is…
Qatar!
SIERRA: The news sent shockwaves through the
world of soccer, and for many fans, it just
didn’t add up.
The host country was not just small, it also
had no sporting infrastructure or domestic
soccer culture to speak of.
Its desert climate reaches temperatures over
100 degrees fahrenheit in the summer, which
is when the Cup is usually held.
And to top it all off, Qatar’s politics
were at odds with Western democratic values.
Allegations of bribery and corruption swirled,
and a long stream of protests began.
At this point, it’s probably worth mentioning
a few things about Qatar itself.
For most of its modern history, it had a modest
stature.
At the beginning of the 20th century, its
economy still relied on pearl diving in the
Gulf.
But in 1939 it discovered more lucrative resources—oil
and natural gas.
By the time Qatar became independent of British
rule in 1971, it had the third largest oil
reserves in the world.
Now, the country is fabulously wealthy, especially
given its tiny population of 3 million, 88
percent of which consists of foreigners and
foreign laborers.
That’s right, there are only about 300,000
native Qataris.
Qatar is a semi-constitutional monarchy that
has enshrined sharia in its legal system,
but it nonetheless seems liberal compared
to its neighbors After all it does observe
some elections, and its the home of Al Jazeera,
which is considered the most independent large
media organization in the Muslim world.
SIERRA: Let's talk about this year's World
Cup.
I've been following along with the World Cup
coverage and so much of it seems incredibly
negative.
Could you speak on this year's World Cup drama
in particular?
DUBOIS: I mean, there are many things that
are peculiar about this World Cup.
For one thing, it's happening at a different
time of year than the World Cup has ever happened
before.
So, it's happening in the winter because of
the heat conditions in Qatar.
It is in a small country with a very particular
social matrix and political matrix.
It is well known that there have been a lot
of human rights abuses and labor abuses in
the construction of stadia.
So, there's a lot of concern, specifically
about the cost, essentially, of this World
Cup, the human cost.
And there have been a series of corruption
scandals that emerged from the awarding of
the World Cup to Qatar and the broader question
of how FIFA makes these decisions.
At the same time, it's the first World Cup
held in an Arab country, in a Middle Eastern
country.
It comes in the wake of several other World
Cups that have, themselves, been controversial
in terms of the politics.
And so, it feels like it's crystallizing things
that have been building, actually for a while,
around the World Cup.
And the fundamental thing I think is this
kind of feeling of contradiction between what
the World Cup is meant to be, which is a celebration
of human contact and of the joy of the sport
and of people coming from all around, and
then the infrastructural, economic, social
dynamics of the World Cup.
And I think we'll be seeing that a lot as
it unfolds and people, journalists and fans,
trying to navigate those contradictions in
certain ways.
SIERRA: Same sex marriage is illegal in Qatar,
and sex between men is technically punishable
by prison sentence.
This has led to widespread frustration among
LGBTQ groups and their allies.
Qatar, for its part, has noted that its laws
are consistent with others across the Arab
world, and that they are generally not strictly
enforced.
The other major issue has to do with migrant
labor.
BBC News: There are just days to go before
the start of the World Cup in Qatar but the
build-up to the event has been blighted by
safety concerns.
France 24: Six-and-a-half thousand migrant
workers lost their lives in the construction
of the stadiums and infrastructure to enable
soccer to be played in the intense heat.
Channel 4 News: Nirmala Pakrin’s husband,
Rupchandra Rumba, died while he was employed
in one of the new World Cup stadiums in 2019.
Rupchandra’s death certificate states he
died of natural causes, a vague term used
to describe thousands of migrant deaths in
Qatar.
SIERRA: In order to build World Cup infrastructure
from scratch, Qatar brought in hundreds of
thousands of migrant laborers, mostly from
Africa and South Asia.
Under the so-called Kafala system, migrant
workers are entirely dependent upon their
employers, leading to unfair or nonexistent
wages, racism, and dangerous working conditions.
Reports have found that thousands of such
workers died during preparation for the Cup.
Taken together, these issues have led some
observers to declare that the Qatar cup has
permanently sullied global soccer.
Others note that this isn’t the first Cup
to transpire amid human rights problems and
political debate.
DUBOIS: I mean, it's worth reminding people,
the World Cup in 2014 was preceded the previous
year in Brazil with a major social movement.
I mean, one that happened during the Confederations
Cup, which is a tournament that happens in
the place that's hosting the World Cup the
year before.
It's a warm up tournament.
But it was a massive protest movement and
people really expressed a lot of disgust with
the fact that the Brazilian government had
had to spend so much money to host this tournament
and build infrastructure that wasn't going
to help the people.
So, there have been huge controversies around
this and thinking back to 2018, this was hosted
by Russia.
Putin presided over the whole thing, certainly
got a lot of help in some ways from hosting
that tournament, in terms of his image.
Something that now, a few years later, strikes
us again as a problematic thing, I think in
ways that many people recognize.
So, this is not the first time, it may be
just stark in a certain kind of way that I
think is bringing things home.
SIERRA: The example of Russia stands out in
particular.
Just four years ago the world was celebrating
France’s victory in Moscow.
Now Russia is engaged in a brutal war that
aims to change the borders of a democratic
neighbor.
Gay marriage?
Also illegal in Russia.
It's a good reminder that the Qatar cup is
only the latest in a series of global events
hosted in the authoritarian world.
SIERRA: Well, in that vein, I want to ask
you about this term sports washing.
I think it's something that people have heard
the term more and more.
So, do you think that you could just go into
that a little bit and how it pertains to this
World Cup?
DUBOIS: The most famous case, maybe this is
Adolf Hitler's hosting of the Olympics in
1936, there were World Cups hosted by Argentina
under dictatorship.
There have been many other cases where you
can point to this.
And the basic idea is that a country that
hosts the World Cup kind of gets to burnish
its image.
It's an opportunity for the country to kind
of be seen by the world in a light that it
wants, right?
And to perhaps, sort of, put under the rug
other problems with the country or political
problems.
SIERRA: Sure.
SIERRA: This trend is pretty salient when
it comes to Qatar.
Remember, it’s a very small country that
has only been independent since 1971.
Qatar has a lot of money, but on the global
stage they tend to be overshadowed by their
larger and more assertive neighbors, especially
Saudi Arabia, Iran, and the United Arab Emirates.
For Qatar, the World Cup was a chance to draw
the world’s eye, and to brand themselves.
And for this they were not only willing to
pay billions of dollars in infrastructure
costs, but billions more to develop a global
soccer profile.
In 2011, one year after winning their World
Cup bid, Qatar purchased the Paris St. Germain
soccer team, following the lead of other middle
eastern countries like Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates.
They proceeded to pour enormous resources
into the team, scooping up world-class stars
like Neymar and Lionel Messi, while purchasing
exclusive media rights to broadcast soccer
around the world.
It has certainly brought them recognition,
but that has also come with scrutiny, and
accusations that they have soured European
soccer by making it impossible for other teams
to compete financially.
The World Cup will be a big test for how much
of a return they get on their investment.
DUBOIS: The issue is that it only works to
some extent because of course, what also happens
is journalists descend on your country.
SIERRA: I was going to say, doesn't it also
call attention to some of the things?
DUBOIS: Yes.
So, it does, in a certain way.
I mean, I think that it's very clear that
the question of migrant labor and the oppression
of migrant laborers in Qatar for instance,
would likely have not been on many people's
radar but for the World Cup.
And it's an issue that exists outside the
World Cup and now it's visible.
So, I do think that there's a double-edged
sword to it.
We're talking about a larger context in which
the investments in sport have really skyrocketed
over the last couple decades.
So, there's a lot of questions of also, ‘whose
money is going where?’
in the professional game.
And so, I think there's a way in which these
things are interlinked and there's no doubt
that the sport is deeply embedded in all these
other troubling questions.
And then at the same time, it can't quite
be contained or controlled by that, because
the thing about it is it's a sport, which
means you have no idea what's going to happen
on the field.
You also, and this I think is maybe important
to emphasize, put on the field players, who
most of the time, in most of their societies,
have often come from pretty marginalized parts
of society.
Right?
A lot of athletes are people who have experienced,
to some extent, the worst of a particular
nation.
They have found in sport a form of social
mobility that they couldn't find in other
places.
So, many, many of the athletes who become
icons during a World Cup represent the nation
they come from in a way very different from
the political or economic elites.
And I think that's part of the double-edged
sword too, is that a country's identity gets
represented by people who in many other cases
wouldn't have the ability to represent that
country in the same way but for the World
Cup.
SIERRA: FIFA likes to claim that the World
Cup is apolitical.
I mean, do you think that's true?
DUBOIS: Absolutely not.
It's sort of an absurd statement.
What they mean by that is, "We don't want
people to say political things that we don't
like or that are controversial."
I mean, is it political in the sense that
it's directly related to elections and countries?
Well, not exactly in that sense, but I mean
if you have a slightly larger sense of what's
political, it's obviously political.
And if you ask yourself, “when do you get
to see your nation in some sense, outside
of just an abstraction?”
You can see the president of the country,
you can see the parliament, you maybe see
the armed forces, you see the flag.
But those are a little bit more abstract.
SIERRA: Right.
DUBOIS: Whereas, the national team just feels
like for a little while you're just looking
at Brazil.
And everyone knows you're probably not going
to win the World Cup, but maybe you have a
good run, you have a couple games.
People celebrate just any World Cup victory.
I mean, just an example, the first game of
the 2018 World Cup, Mexico-Germany, Mexico
defeated Germany, and the earthquake monitoring
division in Mexico City registered a small
earthquake when the goal was scored and when
the game ended, just from people jumping up
and down in Mexico City.
SIERRA: Oh my god, really?
DUBOIS: That wasn't winning the World Cup,
that was just the first game of the group
stage-
SIERRA: Aww, that's amazing.
DUBOIS: But it was a national event that everyone
will remember.
So, there's a way in which, on that level,
I guess it's joyously political in a way that
we sometimes don't think of.
SIERRA: I like that, joyously political.
DUBOIS: Yeah.
SIERRA: I mean, sometimes teams and matches
in the World Cup are seen as symbols for geopolitical
changes and tensions.
So, are there any teams out there that symbolize
a changing world for you?
DUBOIS: There's several powerful examples
in this World Cup.
Probably the Iranian team is one of the most
clear, because there are, obviously given
the situation in Iran and the protests in
Iran, there are many athletes who have started
to express support for the protests.
Some are, it seems, not being included perhaps,
or punished in a certain way.
This happened in 2009 too, where athletes
on the Iranian football team supported the
2009 protests in Iran.
So, there you really see a deep tension, which
is in some ways the Iranian team is an official
team by the federation and therefore in a
sense a kind of governmental representative.
I mean not a formal governmental representative
but they do represent the country.
And yet, I think for a lot of the players,
they think they are representing the Iranian
people who are right now, many of them, in
revolt against their government.
So, I think that's an opportunity for players,
but it's also an opportunity the government
wants to contain.
Sky Sports News: Now before the game, none
of the Iran players sang the national anthem
of the Islamic Republic of Iran.
The captain, Ehsan Hajsafi, said before the
tournament that the national team supports
those who have died in protests across the
country.
DUBOIS: A case that I've written about a lot,
of course, is the French national team and
you can think of other European teams where
you have teams that are actually majority
made up of children of immigrants, often.
And so, who are representing Europe but also
representing home nations, or represent multiple
identities.
And at times you've had people attack those
teams for not representing the country.
SIERRA: Oh, interesting.
DUBOIS: Not representing France.
And of course, they do represent France, they
represent maybe just a different version of
France than other people want to be seen.
SIERRA: Of course.
DUBOIS: We have a US player, Chris Matthews,
who's very strongly invested in Black Lives
Matter and anti-racist activism, and a lot
of players around the world who also speak
up about essentially the issues in their home
countries that they're passionate about.
Athletes can do that in all kinds of settings.
But when you are representing your country
in the most watched sporting event on the
planet, you do have a different kind of platform
that's just on another level.
SIERRA: At the same time, all of these players
are here to win right?
I mean that is what most viewers are expecting
to see when they tune in, like just a good
soccer match.
DUBOIS: I think that there's a way in which
the World Cup gives us a break from other
things, right?
Notably from the political conflicts in our
countries, from the news and everything that's
happening in our world.
It's going to be a time where we can maybe
forget about all that for a while.
And then at the same time, it plunges us right
back into geopolitics, right?
We're thinking about nations and their relationship,
but maybe refracted in a slightly different
way.
And I think that's part of the point, is that
when we're thinking about our nations and
then thinking about the larger world through
the World Cup, maybe it's giving us a more
hopeful way of thinking about that.
I think at the best you can say, can we take
some of that more positive energy about unity
and connection, even affection across differences,
and then bring that into our political lives.
That's what would be the most hopeful version
of what can happen in that context.
SIERRA: So, going from beautiful and inclusive
and amazing, to FIFA, because we have to talk
about FIFA for a moment.
I read a piece that said, "FIFA is actually
more powerful than the UN."
Which seemed maybe impossible to me.
I mean, what's up with FIFA?
DUBOIS: Well, it's such a fascinating, international
organization, and in a sense, I don't think
people have analyzed it enough, just from
a political science institutional background.
They say they’re more important, partly
because there's actually more members than
the UN, because there are places that are
members of FIFA that aren't countries, Palestine,
Caledonia, obviously, the Faroe Islands, et
cetera.
You can mention various ones.
So, they have a larger footprint, I guess.
There are nations that are in FIFA that aren't
recognized as nations otherwise, in that sense.
This is a, originally, a cute, little organization
organized mainly in Europe to organize games
between countries.
And then it grew, especially through the '60s
and '70s, it grew as decolonization happened.
And one of the first things that countries
would do after getting independence would
be, of course, join the UN and also join FIFA.
Right?
As it grew, the power of FIFA grew more and
more, because FIFA can determine a lot of
flows of money.
They decide, of course, where tournaments
are hosted, not just the big ones but small
ones.
And each of those tournaments brings revenue.
They now control the Women's World Cup and
Women's International Tournament, after many
years of not being interested, but in the
'90s they started being interested.
But the real thing is the nexus that happened
in the '80s and '90s when television rights
became privatized and the money flowing into
particular viewing rights became massive,
is that you just have this organization that
controls a nexus of institutional, structural,
and economic power, in a way that does mirror
the UN, in the sense that there's a general
assembly, but then there's this group of people,
group of countries who really have a lot more
control.
PBS NewsHour: People who have even a casual
understanding of what FIFA represents associate
it with corruption, and cronyism, and a lack
of transparency.
WeShow Football: But in no way can FIFA accept
to be responsible for the welfare of workers.
They belong to commercial and industrial companies
of other countries.
Wall Street Journal: The upshot has been a
radical reconfiguration of soccer’s power
structure.
A president can be elected without a single
vote from Europe and South America confederations.
Real Stories: In order to win a bid to host
the World Cup you have to convince a majority
of the 24 voters on the FIFA executive committee.
They are the gods of football.
DUBOIS: And then, people are not as familiar
with this, but there's then the board related
to FIFA, the International Football Association
Board that governs the rules of soccer, which
has a weird structure in that four of those
eight seats are actually just England, Scotland,
Wales, and Northern Ireland.
SIERRA: Oh, okay.
DUBOIS: So, half of that is controlled basically
just by the UK, and then the other four are
rotating.
But in terms of the specific issues, which
is that there is just a huge amount of opportunity
for corruption within FIFA, and who is the
body above FIFA that would police FIFA?
Well, there isn't really one.
And the real question is, does FIFA represent
football fans and players around the world?
Well, not exactly, it really more represents
a set of interests within them,
SIERRA: Let's talk about money.
So, how much money is at play when FIFA selects
a new World Cup host?
DUBOIS: It's really a weird relationship,
right?
Because the country takes on all of the responsibility
for the infrastructure.
This was the issue in Brazil and in South
Africa.
It's not like FIFA gives the country a bunch
of money to build the stadium.
They just require them to build a bunch of
stadia, according to rather specific rules,
actually.
Then FIFA actually totally controls what happens
in the stadia and who gets to sell alcohol
and stuff like that.
SIERRA: Side note, as you may have heard,
Qatar banned alcohol sales in stadia at the
last minute.
This was bad news for many fans, and also
for World Cup sponsor Budweiser, which eventually
decided to award all unsold beer to the victorious
country.
DUBOIS: Food is always really bad at World
Cup games.
You're in South Africa, but you just have
to eat a bad hot dog.
So, it's a weird relationship.
Now, what the country gets in principle, right?
Is people coming to the World Cup, the money
from tourism and those sorts of things.
On balance, I think when people have really
studied it, it tends to be actually at a loss.
The countries tend to have to spend more money
than they get from people visiting, just because
it just doesn't pan out, even if you really
gouge people on their hotels and stuff, which
places do.
I think the reason that politicians go for
it is not really because - they'll argue that
it's good financially for the country, but
really what they're thinking about is themselves.
It's good for them to host this World Cup.
So, it's sort of a losing proposition from
a raw financial perspective, for a country,
generally.
I mean, it does create employment and you
can argue a bunch of different ways about
it.
But I think again, it's more that symbolic
draw.
People are drawn to it like moths to the flame
that they have to be hosting the World Cup.
And of course, it depends on - like when the
United States, Canada, and Mexico host the
World Cup in 2026, to some extent, the infrastructural
investment is going to be less of a big deal
on some level than it was say, in South Africa,
and Brazil, and Qatar, because there's already
a lot of big stadia, et cetera.
SIERRA: To put things in perspective, the
2022 world cup is astronomically more expensive
than previous years.
Qatar has spent more than twice the previous
8 cups combined.
In 2018, Russia spent 11.6 billion, and in
2014, the cup cost Brazil 15 billion.
Typically, countries don’t recoup the costs
immediately, instead they hope the tournament
will have a positive effect on their economy
in the long run.
Qatar, for example, only expects to make back
17 billion dollars of the 220 billion it shelled
out in the short term, and South Africa is
estimated to have lost 2.8 billion when it
hosted in 2010.
Who makes the immediate cash?
FIFA.
Each world cup rakes in billions of dollars
through TV and marketing rights.
SIERRA: It just makes me think of all of the
times that we see the photos of the almost
ruins of the stadiums that they built after
the game.
Whether it's from the Olympics or the World
Cup, I mean it seems like definitely a loss,
not a gain.
DUBOIS: Yeah.
In Brazil, I mean the only people who can
fill some of those stadias are now these big
evangelical rallies, which bring together
80,000 people sometimes.
But yeah, there's no local league that has
enough people to go in those stadia.
SIERRA: So, corruption keeps coming up, you’ve
mentioned it a few times already.
So can you tell me a bit more about that?
DUBOIS: What we're really talking about is
that there are groups of elites or oligarchs
in a particular country, who are deeply connected
with the people who run FIFA and who make
arrangements.
And on both sides, a lot of people are making
a lot of money from that, right?
So, the government officials who decide to
host the World Cup are also often tied to
the contracts and can give contracts to their
friends to build the hotels.
It's not necessarily like someone handed a
suitcase of money in a back alley to someone,
right?
SIERRA: Right.
With a wink.
Yeah.
DUBOIS: It's more just that these things are
so intertwined and the people who decide who's
going to get the TV rights in a particular
country, and which country's going to host
it.
I think it's that corruption that happens
when there's almost no transparency.
Again, what is the body that's going to really
investigate FIFA in a way that is solid?
I mean, even when the Swiss police and the
FBI joined together, they made certain things
stick, but it's actually really hard to investigate
a body like that.
SIERRA: Rumors of corruption have only grown
in the decades leading up to the current World
Cup.
The main accusation is that top soccer officials
within FIFA were bribed into voting for Qatar.
Numerous investigations have been conducted,
and the US department of justice even indicted
16 officials in 2015 for racketeering conspiracy,
and corruption.
Later that year, FIFA president Sepp Blatter
resigned, in part due to the ongoing scandal.
FIFA, for its part, has denied accusations
of bribery, noting that no irrefutable evidence
has been produced.
They have also emphasized that “reform takes
time”.
In the meantime, the FIFA bidding process,
for all of its global impact, remains veiled
in secrecy.
DUBOIS: So, they deploy a ton of power without
much transparency, and then brush off the
idea that there should be transparency by
saying that they're not really that important,
in some ways.
And all of it comes from the fact that they're
controlling something that people around the
world just love and are going to watch, basically.
It's very difficult to convince people not
to watch the World Cup.
There's some courageous French towns that
have said they're not putting up big screens,
to boycott this World Cup because of the human
rights abuses.
But I think most people in those towns will
still watch the French games in their houses.
Its just like you can’t really stop people
going for this.
So, FIFA knows that on some level and no one
in FIFA is elected by their countries.
There's not a way to control them.
And I think that’s part of it so, if you
believe that human beings are often drawn
to corruption when they're not controlled
by some structure, FIFA's a good case of that.
I mean, in the US case, like with the Sally
Yates report that just came about, about sexual
harassment and violence in women's soccer
here, you have a federation that finally after
really not dealing with an issue, I think
is playing an important role in addressing
systemic questions in the country.
SIERRA: Released this past October, the Yates
report exposed extensive sexual and emotional
abuse perpetrated by former FIFA employees
within the women’s professional soccer league.
DUBOIS: These federations are nonprofit organizations.
They're supposed to sustain people who play
soccer in their country.
So, they could and should be forces for good
in their countries, and in some cases they
are more than others.
But I think people deserve better organizations
than they have.
SIERRA: Yeah.
I mean, all this said, are you going to watch
the World Cup?
DUBOIS: Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm falling right into that category.
I wish I could deliver a more morally cogent
statement.
I mean, I do think that, like in lots of other
realms of our lives, there are organisms that
we maybe don't like the way they're run, we
don't believe in all their choices, and we
participate in, nonetheless.
I think we're all part of institutions in
one way or another, or social institutions,
that are like that.
It feels like, to me anyway, there's still
something that is very unique about this event,
maybe in a time like now more than ever, where
I do believe in that initial romantic nature
of the World Cup, that there is something
powerful about human beings being united in
this.
And if we can get a little bit of that and
use that energy to do better as a planet and
as a world, I'm for that.
I also think that people need to call out
the injustices and speak out about what's
done.
There isn't a reason why things had to be
done the way they were in Qatar for building
these, they could have paid laborers better,
they could have treated people better.
And so, I think it's worth calling those things
out as well.
SIERRA: Whenever I think of the World Cup,
I think of, especially lately, just so many
people coming together, rooting for one team,
and I guess once the US is out, another team,
but all in the same bar, all cheering for
the same thing.
And aside from the Olympics and even then,
I don't know anything as powerful as that.
DUBOIS: There just isn't anything else.
And people do, they root for other countries.
There's an interesting openness, right?
You learn about other countries.
At the beginning of the World Cup, you've
never heard of a particular country and then
maybe you fall in love with that country just
because you love the way their team plays.
Suddenly you're super into Croatia.
And I think that’s education, that’s global
education for people.
It does affect the way that you see your country
and your community, and maybe makes you open
in different ways and think about your nation
in a different way.
So, I think all those things are very powerful
and there isn't really any other thing that
delivers it like the World Cup.
SIERRA: Alright, let’s end on a philosophical
note then.
Why soccer?
Why not basketball or baseball?
What made soccer the world’s game?
DUBOIS: It is this really interesting question,
right?
Obviously, sports are a huge part of human
culture all across the world, but soccer just
stands out in the sense that it is present
pretty much everywhere.
It comes out of a particularly specific place
and time, but then it spread so quickly to
Latin America, to Africa, to Asia, and by
the end of the 19th, beginning of the 20th
century, it's already becoming this kind of
global language.
And I think the question I'm always thinking
about is why?
What is it about this particular form that
allowed so many people to embrace it?
I think there are specific things actually
about the nature of the game that allows both
something universal, something that people
share across cultures, which makes it a kind
of language, and that's attractive.
And at the same time, it allows, I think for
people to express very local identities, local
cultures, local ways of being through the
sport.
So, it enables people to both be very rooted
in the way that they play the sport and also
be playing something that they know is shared
across the whole world.
And you can have funny conversations about
this in the United States, because there's
people who love soccer.
There's also people who just really hate it,
who find it boring, incomprehensible.
They don't understand what the thing is.
"Why is the game 0-0?
No one ever scores a goal.
They're flopping around."
We have all heard the critiques and had fun
conversations with soccer haters, and all
legitimate critiques.
People love their sports for different reasons.
But I guess what I would lean into is that
a lot of the things that people who dislike
this sport call attention to as its problems,
I think are actually its virtues.
And what I mean by that is that a lot of the
things about the game create a very emotionally
complex relationship to the game, in that
it is very true that the outcomes of the games
often just don't really feel fair.
They don't really feel like they reflect what
should have happened.
Some kind of stupid mistake by someone.
One instant the game can be going really well
for a team and then they make a stupid mistake
and they lose because of that.
The referees, of course, notoriously, are
dealing with lots of gray areas with offside
calls, with handball calls, with different
kinds of calls that even in the era of VAR
and video assistants, still remain ambiguous
and people argue about them forever.
I have friends who still discuss refereeing
calls from the 1982 World Cup, as if it just
happened yesterday.
Right?
So, it's actually one of the things that people
love doing about the game actually, is to
talk endlessly about basically the system
of justice and how it misfired, and how it's
unfair to them.
And then coupled with that, you just have
moments of beauty and glory and people who
carry out a set of plays that are just incredible
to behold.
So, you have this mix of things that you're
watching, that I think just really reflect
people's lived experience, right?
The mix of possibility and joy and beauty,
and then stupid things happening to you, basically,
unfair things.
SIERRA: Which is universal.
DUBOIS: Yeah, exactly.
Unfair things happening.
Being the best at what you do and still somebody
mediocre gets the job, or something, right?
SIERRA: Yeah.
Right.
DUBOIS: So, I think people relate to that,
actually.
So the game gives you a kind of language to
think about life.
And then that basic core thing, which is then
having to pick yourself up even in the face
of injustice and unfairness and get the energy
to play the next game.
And the one thing that the game offers and
that the World Cup offers is it's going to
keep happening.
But you have no guarantee, in soccer, that
working hard and doing all the things right
is going to lead to the outcome you want.
SIERRA: Wow.
I love that you're looking at that as a positive.
DUBOIS: Yeah.
Well, I think the point is that it's like,
you can want to see sports as a place that's
outside of normal experience.
Which is fair enough, like a place where things
are different from the world and there may
be more fair than the world.
That's not something you're going to really
get in soccer, actually.
SIERRA: There’s no question that some aspects
of the Qatar cup are queasy.
The stadiums were built on the backs of exploited
migrant labor.
LGBTQ fans have been told to ‘tone it down’
if they attend in person.
There is evidence of corruption.
And, in a year when climate effects grew even
worse, it just seems strange to hold the Cup
in a wealthy petrostate.
With all this, it’s understandable that
rights groups and others are frustrated when
fans tune out the noise and enjoy the game.
But there’s another way to look at it.
At a time in history where everything seems
to keep falling apart, the world still has
this funny little game that commands a shared
feeling from billions the world over.
No matter the host country, no matter the
circumstances, the enthusiasm is irrepressible.
And maybe it’s good to remember that’s
possible, if only every four years.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes.
If you ever have any questions or suggestions
or just want to chat, email us at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
audio.
If you have the time and love the show you
could leave us a review - it helps us get
noticed, and we love to read them.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Our associate podcast producer is Molly McAnany.
Our intern this semester is Mormei Zanke.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire Klobucista and Kali Robinson.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you around!